good evening
we need a special drink for tonight
tonight's theme it's not for me we gotta
invent a drink together
together collaborate so that we've got
the drink of the evening the theme is
robotics
on mars on earth
wherever we make them wherever we put
them
so
what out what behind here says robot to
you
uh how about let me think
is there
hmm
how about this let's try some grand
marnier
that translates to grand mariner right
mariner is an explorer yes that's a
start
okay some kind of an explorer we have
robotic explorers in the universe
orange liqueur
all right
and what do you mix this with
you can mix it with anything we got to
give it a backbone
how about
hm
well it's got to be something else
that's not alcohol right so
yeah you could do a juice if you want
juice
uh how about
what's the what's a light juice that you
have because these are robots in space
where in space
no one can hear you scream and no one
can weigh you because you have no weight
i think it tastes good with pineapple
orange and pineapple i like it let's try
that let's try let's try pineapple okay
okay
and just to give it a little more
levitation let's add some salsa
okay let's try that
this has high sugar content so let's add
this last and that way it'll sink to the
bottom through the lower density seltzer
yeah
okay that's good that's good now get
some seltzer
you put in a little bit of seltzer good
and we put some of this in
so now we have a grand marnier
a little bit of pineapple because you
got that orange pineapple mix so we have
the ground mariner and i put in some
salsa which has bubbles give it some
levity
because robots float in space
and they explore
oh man that's good
that's good we've got to call it
something uh
this is really good
okay we got to call it something uh
robot cocktail
it's some good stuff
okay i get to work now
we'll see on stage
you